[Musique]
la france entière est dans la tente je
pense qu'en termes de méthode on
pourrait être un peu plus moderne un peu
plus efficace et jouer un peu plus la
transparence
nous avons eu nous l'avons toujours dit
depuis plusieurs semaines des semaines
difficiles devant nous c'est dans ce
contexte là que le président de la
république s'exprimera ce soir mes chers
compatriotes l'image part de l'elysée et
est envoyé à boulogne billancourt à la
régie de tf1 pourquoi tf1 car cette
semaine c'est tf1 qui s'occupe du pool
tf1 envoie ensuite l'image un
dispatcheur globecast orange qui est
situé en plein centre de paris dans le
3e arrondissement nous sommes entrés
dans une course de vitesse
d'un côté le déploiement de la
vaccination qui permet d'espérer
raisonnablement une sortie de crise et
je vais y revenir et de l'autre la
propagation dans toute l'europe d'une
nouvelle forme de virus
c'est cette boîte qui distribue les
images aux chaînes qui le veulent qui
raque car au rac les grosses chaînes
paye 8580 euros les chaînes tnt paye
6630 euros autre point sensible pour
l'exécutif
l'acceptabilité des français 71% d'entre
eux s'opposent à un durcissement des
mesures d'après un sondage aux docks ça
d'ailleurs
des rassemblements en extérieur se
multiplient commis hier à lyon à lille
quatre cents personnes se sont réunies
hier soir il n'y a pas eu de débordement
on voit d'ailleurs que les participants
ne respectez pas vraiment les gestes
barrières les règles qui sont en vigueur
dans les dix neuf départements en
vigilance renforcée ces règles seront
étendues à tout le territoire
métropolitain
dès ce samedi soir et pour quatre
semaines
quand emmanuel macron va chez le médecin
c'est parce que le médecin est malade et
quand il se lave les mains c'est le
savon qui devient propres voilà le type
de message que l'on peut lire depuis la
publication d'un article du monde dans
lequel l'entourage du chef de l'état se
dit admiratif de ce président devenu
quasiment épidémiologistes veut dire que
le
couvre-feu à 19 heures sera maintenue
par tous on ne connaît pas la taille
exacte des manuels macron car rien n'est
à la hauteur des manuels macro emmanuel
macron se regarde dans un miroir son
reflet baisse les yeux
emmanuel macron ne se lave pas les mains
c'est le savon qui devient pente nord
s'est déplacé et se trouve maintenant à
l'elysée parce que la terre tourne
tourne emmanuel macron chiche au
président de la république à un moment
donné croissance avoir arraché en
épidémiologie pour prendre dans le
domaine épidémiologique des décisions on
va dire sans le souci des avis des
épidémiologistes professionnels qui
modélise ça alors ce serait un
dysfonctionnement de l'état
les sanctions seront renforcés sur la
voie publique pour limiter les régler
rassemblement parce que c'est là que le
danger existe et pour encadrer la
consommation d'alcool mais très
clairement nous faisons le choix de la
confiance
nous faisons le choix de la
responsabilité et si je puis dire de la
respiration
l'attestation ne sera donc obligatoire
en journée que pour les déplacements au
delà de 10 km du domicile
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur ou
son représentant le lundi 22 mars
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
suis donc le représentant du ministère
de l'intérieur
je déplore de voir je ne trouve pas très
non pour la france insoumise mais je
suis très honoré de vous répondre
monsieur le député corbières et nous
allons bâtir entre la mi mai et le début
de l'été un calendrier de réouverture
progressive pour la culture le sport les
loisirs l'événementiel nos cafés et
restaurants poisson d'avril qui a pris
l'eau le groupe volkswagen a été obligé
précisé sa plaisanterie
volkswagen le géant allemand de
l'automobile qui a annoncé vouloir
changer de nom regarder s'appeler
désormais volkswagen
c'est pas la peine de faire ces gestes
là je vous réponds
regardez votre masse monsieur mélenchon
pour commencer s'il vous plaît et je
crois que le respect le respect n'est
pas en option garder votre masque